et je vous propose maintenant un
document l'extrait d'un long reportage
que nos envoyés spéciaux en ukraine
cyril payen à georgia ce bec on
réalisait à épines à une trentaine de
kilomètres de kiev où des combats
acharnés ont lieu la bataille dire pin
carnet de route en ukraine on regarde et
on en parle tout de suite après avec
vous cyril payen sur ce plateau
ça barde ouais ça va ça va je suis prêt
je suis prêt pour la bagarre
allez ça va péter
mais ils sont très proches dont
ces connards sont en train de pilonner
ils essaient de flinguer notre
artillerie on va leur répondre on va
aller réduire ensemble
scolaire oui ça vaut la femme qui en qui
ils ont défoncé le coin coin
une volée
je
voilà pour cet extrait de votre long
reportage réalisé à irin dans des
conditions on le voyait extrêmement
difficile cyril payen vous trouviez à
l'endroit même où un journaliste
américain a été tué il ya quelques jours
oui c'était la première victime mais
j'insiste sur le fait qu'il ya aussi
énormément malheureusement de victimes
civiles et c'est la ville veut lisier
résidentiel de dire ping qui était un
endroit un district de plus de soixante
deux mille dix mille habitants qui est
le point d'accès nord-ouest un une clé
stratégique de cette offensive russe
pour encercler pour assiéger qui sait
dans les jours prochains la ville de
kiev 1 hautement symbolique pour cette
démonstration de force on l'aura compris
depuis un mois lancé par moscou au
moment où on parle les protagonistes de
ce film c'est à dire des résistants des
artistes des engagés volontaires
étrangers sont toujours à la manoeuvre
je peux vous dire que depuis 48 heures
il ya un débordement de violence par air
artillerie tanks les russes tentent
d'avancer il ya une résistance
extrêmement important d'intégrer bas qui
font rage dans cet axe stratégique
encore une fois au nord-ouest on est à
peu près à 15 km du centre du coeur de
kiev donc c'est extrêmement important et
les combats font rage et chacun aura
compris que sir pine beach à tous cet
endroit où nous avons passé dix jours et
bien tomber dans les prochains jours
dans les prochaines heures cela
signifierait le début de l'encerclement
le début de ce siège de la capitale
ukrainienne vous êtes en contact avec
les combattants dont vous nous parlez
qu'est-ce qui vous disent l'aller les
combats s'intensifient quelle est la
situation sur place effectivement et
c'est ça le nouveau 2.0 je dirais d'une
guerre conventionnelle par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu connaître nadia plusieurs
décennies c'est qu'on peut effectivement
communiquer avec artem don qui est
d'origine kozak est un résistant aux
farouches qui est un habitant dire pin
avec sergei qui est un écrin pardon un
soldat d'origine ukrainienne de la
légion étrangère en france qui a donc
tout quitter avec sa voiture française
pour traverser l'europe et rejoindre son
pays natal pour défendre la nation je
rappelle qu'il n'est pas le seul il y a
des centaines de volontaires étrangers
dont certains on ne montrera pas leur
identité mais donc on est capable par le
téléphone par les réseaux sociaux de se
parler donc il confirme qu'il ya une
récré du sens très importante de combat
une pression militaire extrêmement
importante de l'artillerie russe alors
c'est là aussi qu'on est dans une guerre
d'information une guerre de propagande
quel que soit le co2 les le côté tonton
ce qu'on se pose bien sûr moscou
communique on le sait de manière assez
massive et unilatérale sans vouloir trop
divulguer notamment les pertes les
raisons de cette avancée cette offensive
qui aurait dû être est clair et qui
tarde équipe ici un peu pour autant du
côté ukrainien on parlait depuis
quelques heures et bien d'une
contre-offensive ukrainienne dans cette
partie nord-ouest de kiev d'un
encerclement et peut-être même que les
chars russes avaient reculé je crois que
là aussi il faut être très prudent la
l'offensive russe n'est pas aussi bien
mener con que moscou l'avait bien voulu
le faire puisqu'on pensait évidemment
une guerre éclair de quelques jours ça
c'est clair que ce n'est pas du tout
validé mais pour autant faire reculer
cette offensive je rappelle que les
russes attaque sursis fronts en même
temps donc on est loin d'abord de voir
des avancées très positif du côté
ukrainien puisque le temps va peser des
deux côtés autant du côté russe
ukrainien et puis on est vraiment dans
une guerre de propagande dont il faut
faire extrêmement attention si l'on dit
par exemple que les quartiers nord ouest
de kif ont été repris par la résistance
ukrainienne les rues sont encore en
masse très présents sur place qu'on est
il des civils on les voit on les a
beaucoup lu sur ces photos terribles ces
images terribles qui tend et pin via ce
pont qui a été détruit et donc du coup
ils doivent enjamber une rivière etc
vous les avez rencontré aussi mais ce
qui est absolument terrible dans cette
guerre conventionnelle c'est que en fait
c'est vous et nous c'est à dire que l'on
rencontre des gens qui sont des
habitants des quartiers résidentiels
c'est un peu issy les moulineaux
boulogne pour les gens qui connaissent
la région parisienne où nous sommes
aujourd'hui est jour au lendemain se
sont réservé bombardé exactement donc on
voit évidemment énormément de familles
qui avec des conditions extrêmement
difficiles là c'est exactement sur le no
man's land qui est le centre ville dire
pin c'est là que ça se passe les russes
sont à 200 mètres en face c'est ces
familles exemple il ya eu les situations
assez dur on peut le comprendre avec des
gens qui racontent le contact avec les
russes les cadavres et encore une fois
cette normalité qui a volé en éclats en
quelques heures d'éclat dès que la
guerre avec a éclaté et on voit ces
familles entières avec laure leurs
animaux il ya beaucoup d'animaux
domestiques des chats des chiens que
l'on porte quand on essaye de faire
partir mais aussi la réalité des cessez
le feu et des corridors humanitaires on
sait qu'ils aient beaucoup des annonces
faites par moscou au moment où nous y
étions et cela n'était absolument pas
respectée puisque on le voit sur ces
images qu'on nous avons pu quitter hier
pin sous les tirs d'artillerie très très
nourris russes aucun réfugié ne pouvait
passer puisqu'il était également eu sous
le feu nourri de l'offensive russe donc
ça aussi la réalité de la guerre avec
des familles qui doivent fuir mais
beaucoup de civils qui paient le prix de
cette guerre et de cette résistance
ukrainienne contre l'offensive russe la
moitié des enfants ukrainiens auraient
dû fuir leur ont fui leur domicile
depuis le début de cette guerre il ya un
mois jour pour jour merci beaucoup cyril
payen pour ce retour de terrain la
bataille dire pin carnet de route en
ukraine c'est un long reportage à
retrouver bien sûr sur notre site à tout
moment
www.francebillet.com